today's topic andrew tate's banned from
facebook and instagram he's a genuine
young man he has drawn criticism from
online comments particularly from uk
advocacy group hope not hate which
welcomed the most recent ban we welcomes
meta shifts
action to remove andrew tatum we
wouldn't pressure on tick tock to follow
this example they must act now to
prevent further spread of these
extremist views he's banned from
instagram facebook and very likely he's
gonna be banned from other places
so first off i don't think this ban
matters at all
i don't think it matters at all because
i think their attempt is to like stop
this person who their eyes is like
spreading misogyny even if that's how
you view him and that's what you think
he's doing you haven't stopped whatever
the movement he's coming from is he's
just a figurehead
just a face
the issues between men and women this
gender related war that exists in our
society still goes on there's going to
be somebody else who comes in this place
and that stuff will never change the
second reason why it doesn't matter is
that he doesn't even spread his own
videos he doesn't have a youtube channel
where he's spreading all this stuff he
doesn't have a tick-tock channel which
means it's random people who are
spending this stuff responsibly in this
thing they're posting it they're they're
taking clips they're posting it
everywhere they're getting interviews
like
unless you ban all mention of this man
it is impossible to stop it
but the minute so they're gonna be in
every comment section reposting it on
every channel going commentate w and
guess what you can't stop it unless you
ban all mention of it beyond how just
like a bullies all right let's take
ourselves out of we hate this dude okay
or you hate this dude or whoever hates
it i don't care
think about what matters in this which
is
all the young folks who gravitated those
messengers message
were they all somebody who were put
under a spell or
were there a lot of societal issues that
existed that created the perfect melting
pot for someone like this to come to
prominence whether you like it or not be
a fresh and fit any of these red pill
dudes whatever you want to choose
what is it that makes people get drawn
to them and this is what i've been
saying for a long time when i did the
other videos i'm like listen right put
it up for me but i understand why it's
necessary right
you can hate these movements you can be
against them but until you deal with the
underlying societal problems that lead
to these movements everything else is
just putting a band-aid on an infected
wound
that's what it is
that's what it is you're not coming to
the concerns of any of these young men
which whether you like it or not andrew
tate spoke to to some degree well why
can't they choose a bet there are no
better role models i don't know how many
times i've said i get so sick and tired
of [ __ ] women just coming out of the
woodwork to be like well they're better
what role models go ahead point them out
good luck i'll wait because i've had
people send me and you know what none of
them have any advice that are useful on
dating most of them have terrible advice
if any okay and they have little to no
experience so i don't really care to
hear from them so i want i want y'all to
keep the whole formula
we didn't talk about what men were
dealing with for a long time it led to
this now someone starts talking about it
you're like don't speak about it so now
we're going back to the very point
they're like don't plan for this person
don't speak with them well it's like
well people want these issues addressed
no no no get somebody else
there's better role models okay so let
me ask you where all these positive role
models that y'all been encouraging this
entire time where they where are they
where when have they rose to promise why
aren't they going viral
if there's so many good ones out there
and you guys encourage them and support
them and then they should be pushed up
in these algorithms how come it's never
happened
can anyone tell me
there's so many positive ones don't look
at me how come in the last 30 years of
my [ __ ] life i'm not seeing a single
one of these [ __ ] ever promoted
on national television or anywhere else
how come no young men have ever
gravitated towards these people can
anybody tell me
i'll wait
since there's so many
i'll wait tell me where these
[ __ ] are at oh we got one who
bill cosby
[Music]
so i ask you
right and this is the more important
question because get past the ban the
ban is just feel good [ __ ] okay this
doesn't change anything
how do you get to the real problems
which are
the issues that men are facing that they
feel are not being talked about that's
what i want to know like who puts
himself in the it's boys they'll be fine
it's funny it's really funny that they
want men to talk
they want men to like to say what they
got to say and the minute we do
like ah we hate
how we we we this and that in the third
we can't have both people
like we can't have both today's video is
brought to you by raycon we have the
raycon earbuds their new earbuds is more
comfortable they won't budge you put
them in your ears and they will not move
that's what you want you know cause i'm
also a dancer
i want to be able to practice without
having to move and replace my thing
sometimes you want to just isolate
everything out but with the noise
isolation feature on these raycons you
can block out all the noise on you so
you could focus in and zone in on what
you want to be doing and navigating
between the multiple modes that exist on
raycon has never been easier just use
the function toggle below and
considering the price point and how
they're set at half the price of their
competitors i'm unbelievably impressed
with these raycons and if you don't
believe me go check out the reviews with
over 50 000 5 star reviews there's a
reason people are saying this and i
agree if you want in go to buy raycon
dot com slash abba to get 15 percent off
your recon purchase so click on the link
in description below and get 15 percent
off your recon purchase that's on me
you can't have men that express
themselves in the trouble that they got
and be
and tell them to shut the [ __ ] up
because they ain't real problems and
it's not as bad as whatever you can't
have both
you want to do that but you can't have
both like which which is it you always
want men to talk and to open up
we open up about a [ __ ] and
the other day the other day i was
talking and i was triggered and i was
talking about
whatever you saw the clip right and i
was
tired of being told like that it was not
black enough and this and that it was
often i told exactly who the perpetrator
is that was me opening up
that was me opening up and being frank
and being real with y'all
a couple y'all uh couple of y'all
dropped me my dm there's one particular
lady that dropped in my dm i didn't read
the whole message but whatever the
minute i saw that i i switched i'm if
i'm a follower i'm a follower but i
gotta be i gotta say that i'm a bit
disappointed in you first and foremost
i'm not your dad okay i'm disappointed
you have to understand what the woman
what the black woman is saying at that
point that was not the point of my
intervention i told on this sound
channel many many times that i
understood
i do
understand
that's why most time i shut the [ __ ] up
but i gotta tell that you [ __ ]
are the perpetrators sometimes when you
open up you're being told to shut the
[ __ ] up so how do we solve it and who's
the role model
there's a reason why that guy gets so
popular like he said it's not some kind
of spell
it ain't magic
you have you have to ask yourself okay
why
you know people say this stuff well we
shouldn't platform these people you know
one of my personal takers i want to hear
these people when i listen to andrew i
don't buy into a lot of the stuff he
says i think a lot of that shit's goofy
i think he's kind of that's me
personally but i want to hear it you
wanna know why because i'm like i
understand why he is the way that he is
and i'm not with that and i understand
why i'm not and someone else can look at
him like i identify with that i'm with
them okay
then the next step beyond that is
we all have a better understanding of
what we agree or disagree with and then
somebody else who's a much better role
model quote unquote apparently you guys
have him can come out and show just as
much charisma and be just as drawing and
then
we have all these ideas conflicted
but unfortunately that doesn't happen
you want to know why because there is no
other side
so now they just see this guy getting
bigger and bigger with no counter voices
and now they want to ban it to make
themselves feel better you didn't offer
a healthy solution right you didn't say
why oh you didn't you didn't say how
we're going to fix a problem you just
said get rid of him
get rid of the figurehead now of course
there's young impressionable people and
they're going to be swaying it's going
to cause problems but i would argue
these are problems that we have to deal
with these are problems that we have to
deal with as society and confront this
issue rather than just trying to ban it
outright and not discuss the problem
because if we're honest nobody's trying
to talk about it i've watched a bunch of
the news coverage on this dude that was
happening on mainstream channels and you
know what they were just saying oh he's
a misogynist and he's inappropriate for
young people why are the young people
gravitating towards them what are the
issues how can y'all never spend time
discussing that no okay
i just noticed a pattern i noticed a
pattern and the reason why i'm telling
you all this when you're watching
whether you hate him or love i don't
care
this is gonna happen a hundred times
more and it's gonna be amplified and let
me also say this when you bang somebody
you know what happens
you just create a hero
because they people who want information
for themselves like why are you guys
keeping me from this guy let me hear him
and then they're going to listen to a
couple of his clips right the more tame
ones that are allowed to stay online and
be like this guy makes a lot of sense
you know he's talking about the fact
that a lot of young men are lonely like
i get that
why is this got banned you guys are
going to create somebody who's pretty
much unbeatable
and now so there you go
it's just weird the way
hold up didn't they just ban trump yeah
didn't they just ban trump ain't he
about to win for a second [ __ ] term
he did try not to make that happen but
but yeah you know the thing is square to
how you act is you think this guy this
andrew tate guy is a cancer right so
he's a symptom of a cancer really
by removing him and not addressing the
root the cancer just comes back stronger
that's what you're doing
that's what you're doing
if you just remove the lump
without addressing
the root the cancer comes back stronger
you're not solving the issue
that's what you're doing
that's what you're doing if i have a
recurring pain oh well you have
why why do you want to address that you
have other functioning body parts in
your body that's what you're doing
that's you
that's you you have other other places
that are working in your body you're
good
it don't work like that
if i have an issue i have to address the
issue and sometimes to address the issue
and to fix the issue you have to
comprehend it
if you don't understand and you just
remove it you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're doing
but that's just me so i understand why
he's banned i just went on the technical
tournament right but i understand the
fact that
that's not how you solve this the
situation but i just didn't want to
repeat myself from other videos that we
did yeah well listen let us know what
you guys think you guys agree or
disagree um we want to hear from you
guys you guys think it's a good thing do
you think it's going to lead to a better
world or do you think it's just more of
the same i want to hear from you
you know what's going to happen